all the rain snow and hail would fall
toward the Arctic at the center of the
Earth the precipitation would converge
and start to build up
the oceans would get sucked to the
center of the disk too and form one big
ocean in the middle
a big concern would be the air pressure
on a flat Earth
gravity would draw too much air toward
the Earth's center leaving the areas
around the edge with no air pressure at
all
that would be bad because people living
in a flat Earth Australia wouldn't have
enough oxygen to breathe
and if you lived closer to the Middle
where the Arctic would be you'd be
crushed by the weight of the atmosphere